hey youtubers is Charlie there's a new
Game of Thrones footage that dropped on
TV we don't have an official trailer
online but it's gonna be the same
footage they're just in keeping with the
tradition of a lot of people dropping
really big trailers like Captain America
stuff or Batman V Superman stuff during
sporting events instead of during
traditional genres stuff like you would
expect it they're just trying to hit a
different audience so just careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far we're just gonna be
talking about the new stuff in this
footage there's a little bit of new
dialogue but we get the same speech from
Tyrion say you're playing the great game
of Thrones now as it jumps from scene to
scene
Daenerys playing the game of Thrones
Sansa is going to be playing the game of
Thrones this season in addition to the
people that have been playing it this
whole time like Margaery and Cersei
speaking of which we get a better shot
of that scene in King's Landing at the
great set with Jaime's surrounded by
Tyrell soldiers they're trotting
Margaery out the faith is trotting
around so it looks like the queen of
thorns is going to try and take her back
by force I really love the jaqen H'ghar
voiceover though when he says one way or
another a face is going to be added to
the hall so it sounds like Arya is going
to be presented with a situation where
she does have trouble killing Meryn
Trant was a slam dunk for her but living
his blind Arya giving the gift of the
many-faced God the gift of death is
gonna be a big test for her so it's
gonna be really exciting plus it looks
like she's going super parkour I love
the idea of badass blind ninja Arya and
speaking of badass what about the Tower
of joy flashback here dual-wielding
Targaryen it's really hard to tell who
some of these people are but these two
people are wearing stark leather so I
think we can go ahead and say that one
of them is young Ned Stark the other
might be Howland Reed
I don't know necessarily that he'd be
wearing stark leather but if they're
gonna be faithful to the books then it
would have to be Howland Reed without a
doubt though the biggest WTF are the
night's king grabbing brands arm which
just looks like a continuation of this
scene here in one one crashing through
the gates at Winterfell
I cannot wait to see one one rekt the
[ __ ] out of some Bolton's the
counterpoint for this is drogon flying
over vias Dothrak
looking like he is in for the BBQ of a
lifetime so it's a bit weird looking at
all these images of Daenerys that looks
like she's going to have to prostrate
herself in front of Khal jhaqo in the
Dothraki and asked them for help like
look I'm here by myself
people aren't with me I don't have an
army at my back but then Drogo just
flies in just in the same way one one
just crashes through the gate at
Winterfell I don't want to assume
anything but I do wonder if that's gonna
happen in the same episode that would be
crazy this scene here could be Tyrion
visiting Daenerys dragons Rakel and
Viserion underneath the pyramid I really
hope that he lets them out a lot of
people think that he might be getting
Quentin storyline from the books I don't
think it'll go down exactly the way
Quentin storyline does but I do think
there'll be some similar things don't
you just love the idea that both Cersei
and Tyrion are unleashing monsters on an
unsuspecting populace Cersei unleashing
zombie mountain Tyrion unleashing
dragons jumping back to the night's king
though I know a lot of you are wondering
from that behind-the-scenes footage and
I'll add a link for that in the
description if them in the root system
is going to be underneath the wall it
seems like the same root system where
they would be shooting bran and
three-eyed Raven scenes but it is
totally possible that they could find a
way underneath the wall if they're not
gonna go through it the only reason I'm
not so sure about that
is because there's two seasons left and
once they get south of the wall all hell
breaks loose people in King's Landing
like Cersei people in positions of power
can still deny the threat of White
Walkers as long as they're not on their
doorstep like oh that's some rumor that
the free folk are spreading north of the
wall they're all full of [ __ ] we
don't have to listen to them that's not
our problem
once the night's king's army makes it
south of the wall they just start
collecting bodies upon bodies their army
would grow exponentially even though the
north isn't quite as densely populated
as the south they would spread like
wildfire so I'll just I'll be very very
surprised if they do make it south of
the wall during season six maybe they'll
leave it on a cliffhanger where they're
starting to approach the wall to start a
season seven but it remains to be seen
usually there is some sort of oh [ __ ]
moment that they try to end on like Jon
Snow I think they'll try and repeat that
with another similar oh my god that just
happened moment and really like the only
other big thing we see in the trailer is
Brienne attacking Bolton's soldiers in
the north so looks like she's gonna try
and help Theon and Sansa and then Theon
is meeting with someone that might be
his sister so what's gonna happen is is
I'll try and do a new game of Thrones
bonus video this Sunday or sometime on
Monday if they
do post a shiny HD version of this all
totally added to whatever next video I
do giveaway time though congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner
Emily Cummings you win a copy of the
season 5 DVD or blu-ray just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details is on the about page just send
me a private message the next round of
the giveaway will start whenever I post
my next game of Thrones bonus video so
be sure to subscribe to get that and if
there's anything specific you guys want
me to do
or anything confusing from the last
couple of trailers or the
behind-the-scenes stuff just let me know
in the comments it's crazy to think we
are within like the 1 month period but
while you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for that
behind-the-scenes white Walker video and
you can click here for like the full red
band Season 6 trailer thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you